alright so welcome to the proposal
research proposal defense of Nathan
Lazar so my name is kim also más o menos
professor in the department so Nathan
came to us with a bachelor's in
mathematics from Ohio University and a
master's of science and mathematics from
Portland State and I remember first like
meeting with him he had run up his bike
on the hill and we kind of didn't meet
like at the right down like the first
day I guess but then we connected and so
he came as a master student first and
then the next year he was secured a
random fellowship so mathematics is
really one of the very I think great
preparations you have you can have for
this site called the kind of thing that
Nathan does which is sort of really
modeling at a deep level so today he's
going to talk to us what about what kind
of research is proposing so he has
looked at several things in the past and
now is sort of working with his
committee he has put together a research
proposal 12 without further ado oh
thanks mom and thank you all for coming
and thanks to the people that are
watching out there including my father
who's been waiting since 1130 eastern
time ok so my proposal here is about
these bayesian tensor factorization
method and applied to drug response and
cancer cell lines so I'll just jump
right in because there's a lot to get
into this is a four-dimensional
hypercube just to give you something to
look at while I do my outline so talk
about the motivation behind a method why
I'm addressing this problem some
background on this tensor stuff current
approaches towards the cell line drug
prediction problem
my three aims and some preliminary
analysis of the data that I've done that
proves to me or shows to me that this is
likely to be fruitful in the timeline
for the the rest of the project so just
as an overview this is kind of in the
broad category of trying to move towards
precision medicine so we know that
basically all patients don't react to
drugs in the same way and certain drugs
will be less effective in smaller
certain populations of cancer patients
so what we really need to move towards
is this idea of precision medicine where
we do some type of categorization of the
patient looking at their genomics or
other markers in order to decide on what
drug treatment will be most efficacious
in that particular pain patient so one
way to do that we can't really test a
bunch of different drugs on one patient
right that wouldn't work well so if we
can get some type of smaller system
where we can test these drugs in the
dish and see which drugs might work for
a particular patient and then move that
towards the clinic that's a lot more of
a tractable problem so the way to do
that one way to do that is to extract
cells from the patient and then grow
them in addition this this is a cancer
cell line these are hela cells which was
the first cancer so on to be developed
back in the 50s and then test drugs on
these and see what strokes are likely to
work for that patient if we can do this
in a high-throughput way then we can
understand more about the genetic the
relationship between the genetics and
the response so drug therapy so this is
one of the smaller of a 96-well plate
from a smaller one of these such
experiments or you can put either the
same cell line in each of these little
wells or different cell lines on each
well treat them with different drugs at
different doses and then after they're
grown normally for three days you image
these or get some add some marker or
fluorescence that shows you how many
cells are alive after three
days of treatment with that drug and
that gives you an indication of whether
the drug is able to stop the cells from
proliferating or kill them so the main
problems that we can dress with this
type of system is this drug
recommendation that I've kind of been
talking about and the discover
relationships between the genetics or
epigenetics of the cell lines and the
structural elements of the drugs but
there's a big problem here in what do we
mean by response to drug treatment okay
so there's a bunch of different ways to
try to characterize whether a certain
cell line responds this is kind of the
typical picture that we expect to see
from treatment with cell line so a
treatment of a cell line with some drug
so across the x-axis these are different
concentrations of the drug for each
concentration we get one read out of the
number of cells after growing it in
culture for three days or whatever in
looking at the fluorescence indicating
how many cells are present so normally
we have measures in triple couture
hopefully in triplicate some type of
replication here so each one of these
dots represents maybe the median
response at that concentration in terms
of the number of cells and as you
increase the dosage if the drug has some
effect it will decrease the number of
cells that grow at that that dosage so
we kind of from chemical studies I've
seen a lot of these curves and
oftentimes they fit this type of
logistic regression hillslope curve goes
down on the right so in order to assess
response what normally people's what
studies do is look at this Hill scope
slope curve fit it to the data that they
have and then extract one or one measure
normally or sometimes a couple measures
more recently on whether that cell line
is really responding to that drug some
of the ones that are often used as the
ic50 which is inhibitory concentration
or ec50 is an effective concentration
and the 50 stands for the halfway point
so the ic50 is halfway between the
no effect up here in the absolute zero
of killing of all cells the ec50 is
halfway between no effect and the
biggest effect seen you can also look at
the largest effect scene or this
theoretical possible maximal effect
according to the curve or the area under
the curve which has been more recently
used as the shaded underneath this
logistic curve and as we look at each
one of these different values it would
kind of change the way the shape of the
curve looks but there's a problem with
using these measures in that they don't
always correlate well with each other so
depending on which measure you use as an
outcome you might see different things
this was a paper by joe gray at laura
and others here at ohsu showing that the
metric that you use to assess whether
the drug is effective really varies
across different drugs and cell lines so
this is a figure from that paper what
we're seeing across the x-axis each of
these is a different drug and then for
each drug we have three different
measurements the ic50 the Emax and the
log to log base two of the hill slope
coefficient and then for each one of
those drugs we have a box plot of across
I think 53 cell lines showing the range
of responses of those cell lines to that
drug for that measure and then in the
top panel we're ordering these according
to decreasing IC 50 values so if I order
these according to the median IC 50 for
instance for this one drug gemcitabine a
way it's a it stops DNA replication it's
got a wide range of response across
those different cell cell lines but in
the order across that we see that
there's no real correlation between what
we see in the IC 50 what we see in the
Emacs or the hill slope coefficient so
which measure of outcome that we use is
going to really change what we see here
this is some real data that from what
I'm going to use for my first name that
I chunk through just to get a sense of
what these slopes actually look like
whether we can fit these logistic curves
to the data and make sense of it but
first thing I want you to notice is that
the ranges here are very different so
this is the raw output readings of the
cellular growth after a certain after in
this case three days and treatment with
the different doses of the drugs so and
secondly the the replicates are kind of
in some cases all over the place in
other cases really tight together I fit
a logistic curve to this and find the in
this case the ic50 value the halfway
between the max and the min and it might
be informative or it might not in all
these cases it's not really showing us
much of what we would think in terms of
whether the so I'm is responding to that
drug treatment okay it's very flat here
we still get ic50 because the
mathematics is going to give you
something no matter what here we don't
really know if its bottom doubt right we
might have a much bigger response if we
go up to higher doses so the ic50 we
could extrapolate this curve and set it
where we think it might be or we could
set it to the maximum value and
different studies use different ways of
fitting this curve either with logistic
curves or more complex Gompertz curves
or sometimes just linear functions
depending on what the data look like
they use different ways of throwing out
data that don't look good they use
different ways of setting the values
when they don't make sense with the
normal curve either setting this to the
max or extrapolating encouraged so which
tends to lead to low reproduction across
different studies because they're all
doing something different in order to
come up with these outcomes and then
trying to match those to genomic
properties of the seller all right so my
idea is let's get rid of all these
measures and with some fairly new
mathematical techniques we can just
predict the whole curve for every cell
line drug combination and after that we
can look at these individual measures of
outcome ic50 area under the curve
whatever you want if we can predict the
whole curve we can measure those later
predict the whole curve ask questions
later this is a kind of multitask
learning so instead of just trying to
learn one value for each cell wide drug
combination we're trying to learn say
nine different doses values so what are
we going to take as inputs will have
ohmic profiles of the cell lines so this
is gene expression mutation copy number
whatever kind of characterization of the
genetics of the cell line that we can
have and from my method we're going to
have target and structural information
on the drug so things that tell us about
the shape of the drugs what kept what
chemical structures are present so on
and for the second name something about
the experimental differences between
different studies because I'm going to
be combining study and our output is
going to be the cell count at each dose
and ideally we want to be able these are
kind of our ultimate goals of being able
to handle a lot of missing data because
that's normally the case some of these
experiments don't work for one reason or
another we want some measure of
uncertainty we'd like to be able to make
predictions for cell lines that aren't
in the model already or drugs that are
in the model already we want to use the
model to be able to identify some
genetic predictors of why does this cell
line respond to this drug and if we it
would be nice to be able to learn the
kind of model parameters along with the
model and some conditional dependencies
between the elements of the model so how
can we do this this is where the tensor
idea comes in this is my first picture
of a kind of tensor this is that same
data that I showed some of the
dose-response curves for that I'll be
using an aim one the first frontal slice
here is a matrix of values where red is
higher and blues lower showing the count
of the number of cells present after
growing for any particular cell line and
drug combination so you notice there's
some missing data here and then as we
move back towards the back of this cube
this is as the dosage is increasing so
eyes red is high and blues low so we're
getting you can see kind of more blue in
the back there because as the curves go
down towards the end so this is the
central object that we're going to be
trying to fill in missing values on
okay and it combines all the cell lines
and drugs and doses into one object that
can kind of leverage information of each
dimension off of each other all right so
that's a tensor what are we going to do
with this testers so we're going to
decompose it we're going to break it
into pieces into matrices that will tell
us individual binary relationships
between two one dimension of the input
data and some latent factors and by
incorporating some probabilistic
Bayesian methods we should be able to do
all of those goals that I laid out in
the previous slide so this is a little
bit of background on previous stuff
that's been done with tensors in machine
learning these are starting to become
more popular the first decomposition
method was written about in 1927 but
didn't really start to get used until we
have computational power to deal with
these things so starting in the 70s and
more and more recently but this
particular study was interesting I think
just visually because what they're
trying to do is identify a picture of
the identified person based on their
picture and they separate the dimensions
of that picture into the identity of the
person which is going along the kind of
back axis here and the angle from which
the picture is being viewed which is
going across the front and the light the
angle from the light the illumination so
they're able to take a specific picture
and decompose it into these three
aspects and then in order to identify
what the person is you just want to look
at the identity portion of it so by
factoring this tensor you can decompose
these type of separate relationships
within the data another more bio
informatics use of tensors was published
2007 here by orally alters group she's
huge in the field and this was looking
at DNA microarray data so expression of
genes over time one of the gene
expression data sets that they used was
from Paul Spellman 1980 1998 paper which
is kind of all over the place I mean not
over the place in the bad way but used a
lot so it looked at expression
of jeans mentees and tried to get groups
of genes or eigen genes that were
expressed in kind of the same pattern so
that each gene could be made up of these
different components of types of
expression kind of over overarching
themes of expression for different
groups of genes all right so before I
move into exactly my model let's look at
what other people have done for trying
to predict the responsive cell lines to
drug treatments this was a paper by Adam
Margolin who's here at ohsu which was a
really a high-throughput way of
examining all the kinds of models that
are out there now to see which what what
was most important about modeling and
trying to solve this problem so he had
over 110,000 different combinations of
models so the things that he varied were
the type of input data and the algorithm
that was used the type of output data so
whether we're trying to predict the ic50
or the area under the curve and whether
that output was by an airy or continuing
so and for each of these models they're
there in the category of where we're
only looking at one drug at a time areas
right now we're only looking at one drug
at a time but all the cell lines so
we're using information from all their
cell lines to try to predict the
response to one particular drug and
examining what what attributes of that
type of model is bested predictive
performance so what they found on this
paper was that first of all
incorporating more cell line ohmic data
more gene expression or copy number data
is more important than what algorithm
you used as long as you use a decent
algorithm secondly among algorithms the
elastic net or Ridge regression perform
the best these are some type of
regularization methods that induce some
sparsity to the solution that the tends
to make it more generalizable and our
method the bayesian tensor factorization
with a bayesian prior on some of the
matrices and the factors
we'll be somewhat similar and also they
found that the continuous area under the
curve measure was the best for
prediction and they hypothesize that
it's the best because it takes the full
curve into accountants in some way which
again indicates that taking it what
we're doing predicting a full curveball
at once is a good idea so another way to
try to assess what's the best method out
there for solving this problem is to fix
a data set input and output data and
then release that to the world at large
and let machine learning people all
compete and try to whoever can do the
best job of predicting the outcomes
given that data set so that was done by
the dream challenge here also organized
by Laura here who's here and Joe gray
and the best performing algorithm was
done by Matt going in in his group which
was a colonel method and it was unique
to the all the methods that I mentioned
in the previous study in that instead of
trying to predict the outcome for one
particular drug at a time it actually
incorporated all the drugs and all the
cell lines into one model so that
knowledge about the response of a cell
line to one drug could help inform the
prediction for a different drug so this
is a bit of figure from their paper
about this multi task multi colonel
learning the algorithm where they
combine information from all the drugs
and all the cell lines through this type
of matrix multiplication to the central
object in this case predicting the GI 50
values across all all cell lines all
drugs the same time they expanded this a
little bit further incorporating not
just all this cell line data so up here
we have the genetics of the cell line
mutation copy number stuff but also
incorporating outside information about
the structural elements of the drugs and
targets and fingerprints so with the
previous method we just had information
on the cell lines now we have
information on the cell lines and the
drugs that we're using to predict the
outcome of
response between the cell lines and the
drugs and another thing that this allows
at school is that we can add in a new
cell line with it with its genetic
characterizations and predict the
response for a new cell line a new drug
or even ultimately a combination of a
new solid in a new drug so my method
expands on this by kind of taking it up
another dimension adding in the response
that each cell line at least for the
first aim so this is my first aim it's
going to be a three-dimensional tensor
factorization method and the data that
I'm using is the Laura Heiser Dougray I
have data of 70 breast cancer so on 90
drug treatments all done fairly
uniformly so I don't have to worry as
much about differences in experimental
procedures so we'll compare it to
current methods that I mentioned
previously on the these measures after
predicting the whole curve and we'll
look inside the model to try to figure
out if it you know it has a good does a
good job of predicting response how does
it do that what what genetic information
is it using to predict response what
structural information on drugs is it
using to predict that response so this
is a picture of what the models look
like the model is going to look like so
we start off with this cell line data so
we think of this as each column or sorry
each row here is this one cell line and
each column represents some genetic
information on that cell line so it
could be the expression of a certain
gene or whether that genes mutated in
some binary marker we take that matrix
and multiply it by this projection
matrix to reduce its dimension down to a
smaller may trigger so in this
projection matrix I think yeah there we
go so I've got one cell line x if i
multiply that by a row here i get one
value in this latent matrix so the sorry
column of the projection matrix is going
to kind of pull out salient information
which genes what expression of which
genes matter or what mutations matter
going into this latent factor I do that
across here and I get a whole row of
latent factors so the same
line is represented here but instead of
being huge matrix of all the genetic
information have this reduced
representation of genetic information
we're the only the important things have
been pulled out and that happens from
the learning process so the great things
here observed I know the cell line data
I know the central tensor of outcomes I
know the drug input data and by doses
which is just a vector what I'm learning
is the green thing so I'm learning how
to project that down to a smaller space
and these blue guys are all latent
factors so there's some representation
of the gray data that's been reduced and
dimensionality to go into the central
tensor objec and by putting a bayesian
prior that enforces some type of
sparsity on these latent factor
projection matrices sorry not Layton but
projection matrices I can make sure that
I only pull out say certain genes the
expression of a smaller number of genes
for every cell line that will predict
its outcome to to the drug this is just
a quick overview of the data we've seen
this one before that's the central
tensor this will be some input for the
cell lines this isn't quite all the data
sets that I plan on using but it has
subtype information some extreme
expression gene copy number and gene
methylation data so this is that long
matrix on the left and this is one of
the data types that i'll be putting in
putting as drugs these pubchem binary
fingerprints they're basically ones and
zeros in this matrix and again I have a
drug here on each row and for each
column it's a one specific structure
inside that drug so maybe it's a six
carbon ring or a six carbon ring with a
hydroxyl group and it's just a one or a
zero as to whether that's present as
part of the chemical formula of the drug
so by having this as my input I can
start to tease realities out
relationships between the genomics of
the cell line and the actual structural
features in the in the drug so just to
kind of go through the math out a little
bit more explicit so that you guys can
be clear on exactly what the methods
doing I'm going to reduce the mission
shins down to just two D for a minute
and talk about PC a principal component
analysis which hopefully most of you
seen before so this is just for one drug
tamoxifen what I have here is these are
basically all night oast response curves
put together and instead of seeing them
go downhill we're seeing the change
color from red to blue so a higher
expression is in red lowers and blue so
we see the kind of slopes that we expect
in some of these right we're high here
and then we dive down the blue for the
last two doses so if i factor this with
principal component analysis what that
really does is split this matrix into
two different matrices in a specific way
so that I'm capturing most of the
variants in the first column of this
matrix and whatever is left over in the
second column and so on if I look at
just one row of this principle component
so this wood is my kind of latent
representation of the cell line matrix
across these principal components I look
at the just a top row here what's
happening i've got a strong blue here
and then pretty much everything else is
zero that's going to get x columns in
this matrix right so the strong blue is
getting multiplied by this right across
the top and that gives me one value up
here I'm doing that for each of these
values so all the other values in this
matrix don't matter much because these
others are close to zero but the strong
blue is pulling out this red band across
the top and blue is a negative value red
is a positive value so I get a negative
times a positive here this gives me a
negative value or a low blue value or a
white value kind of a low expression so
what this is kind of telling me is that
for this particular cell line all that
matters is this first row of the
principal component matrix and that
first row is kind of evenly distributed
across all doses and it's just saying
that this cell line has kind of a low
expression across all doses not much is
going on it's just a and this is really
in my mind relates to the cell cell line
growth rate right because we're treating
this with a bunch of different doses and
then no matter what dose we treat it
with there's only you know there's kind
of a low growth of that particular cell
line at all those doses
alright if I look at this cell line on
the other hand though well you see that
it goes from red to blue so it's really
showing a response and it starts off
with strong expression so let's look at
what is happening in its principal
component decomposition so in the first
principal component we've got this
strong red so that's pulling out a
strong response from this top row across
here which means that it's for the first
you know aight doses it's got a pretty
strong red response ok so this is a
fast-growing cell line the second
principle component also has a strong
fairly strong red here and that
correlates to this second row so the
second row is doesn't really care about
the first seven doses but the last two
doses have a strong response there so
that's pulling out the fact that we
change from a high red to a low blue so
that's really saying something about the
response here the second principle
component seems to correlate with
response which was really exciting when
I first saw it right we're pulling out
the most important information is just
the general growth rate of the cell line
which is often normalized out in these
types of studies so people ignore it
we're capturing that information and
including it in the model and it's the
first principal component that's fine
well what we really care about more is
probably the second principal component
so this is just kind of a zoom-in that's
the first principal component if I look
across these different cell lines i can
see everywhere there's a red like a kind
of higher expression of that so I'd in
general everywhere there's a blue
there's a lower expression of that cell
line but if i zoom in on the second
principle component everywhere there's a
strong read those are cell lines that
are responding to treatment they have
some that the drug is actually effective
at some dos and the third principle
components doing something cool as well
it's kind of telling us whether that
drug or whether that's how I'd responds
to the drug early or late so if I have a
blue it's responding at the last dose if
I have a red it's responding a little
bit earlier so this is maybe something
similar to the ic50 telling us at what
dose we need in order to get that
response all being captured in the same
model and this is just two dimensions so
when a problem with the two dimensions
is that if I were to do this for a bunch
of different drugs I might not see the
same principle components for each drug
right so by combining this in the in the
three
dimensional tensor and doing something
very similar I make sure that I have the
same type of latent representations for
every drug and that they all make sense
on a grander scale all right so how do I
split apart a tensor into these types of
principal components there's two main
methods for doing that so this is my
central tensor that I'm starting out
with the responses the CP method was the
one published in 1927 this kind of the
earliest method the other one was just
as soon afterwards a mathematical on it
that's fairly old and the idea behind
this is we can take any tensor and split
it into a kind of simple tensors that
are that we thought of as just a product
of three vectors so I just have three
vectors and I multiply every possible
number and every one of those vectors by
every other one and put them in order
i'll get a tensor but that tensor
doesn't really hold a lot of information
it's just holds as much information as
three tensors the rank will intensive so
i can split any tensor into a summation
of Rank 1 tensors there might be a lot
of these if I cut off that summation at
some point i'll have some error left
over for those that I'm not not taking
into account each one of these is kind
of weighted by this central cube of how
much how much those influence the values
in the ultimate output if I take then if
I collect all the green vectors and put
them into a matrix side by side by thick
and all the red and all the blue I get
these factor matrices and if I define a
type of multiplication I can think of
this as instead of a summation of these
Rank 1 tensors it's a multiplication of
these factor matrices and those are
combined through this core tensor which
in this case only has values along the
diagonal and moreover each of these
matrices has the same column dimension
because it came from just the summation
of in this case are of these great
cleansers so I'm splitting this into n
by are well in this case I 1 by r I to
by r3 by are matrices so in my
experiments this wasn't good enough to
fully capture all the information that I
need from my response tester so the
second type of tensor decomposition is
a little bit more flexible in that each
one of these matrices can now have a
different column dimension so they're
not forced to all be the same size
basically so let's just look at some
data on what that does so if i take that
tensor that i showed you earlier and
this was just trying to try to
understand whether i can take that
tensor break it apart into pieces put it
back together and still have all the
information there that i started out
with and what size of those pieces have
to be what are the dimensions of my
factor matrices that need to make sense
so if i try the CP decomposition in this
case a 10 by 10 by 10 so i started with
just 24 cell lines that i had
information for 90 drugs at 10 doses i
split it into a 2424 by 10 and a 90 by
10 and a 10 by 10 factor matrices with
the CP decomposition put them back
together and then looked at those
dose-response curves that's what we're
seeing in the top row of graphs here so
the actual observed values are blue the
predictive values are in red or
reconstructed values really and we can
see that the red well they don't match
well but they did get the kind of range
in general right so it is capturing some
information this goes from in this case
just a 3000 while this one goes of six
thousand or so so the red is capturing
some information but it's not enough to
really see the intricacies of the curve
but if I do a seat Tucker decomposition
instead which in this case reduced each
of the dimensions by half well it
reduced the cell line and the drug
dimension by half so compressing my
total information by a factor of 4 and
then building it back together again I
can reproduce pretty well the actual
shape of the response curve right so
this tensor factorization method the
things I really give me hope that this
is going to work well is one pca seems
to make sense in just looking at the
previous stuff I showed with factoring
the doses and to this tensor
factorization method seems to be able to
hold the data and break it apart put it
back together in a reasonable way just
to look at some of the factor matrices
from that tensor decomposition of the
second one the Tucker one this is the
latent
ders for the cell line and the drug kind
of hard to interpret but if i look at
the latent factors for the doses this
looks very similar to what i saw in the
pca the first latent factor for the dose
is kind of spread across the early doses
and kind of tells you the general growth
rate well the second late latent factor
might be telling you something about
whether the cell line responds to the
drug or not and the third one might be
telling you whether it responds early or
late so the same type of patterns are
cropping up in this method and these
factor matrices are combined through
that central core tensor these are
slices through the core tensor so these
kind of tell you the weight that's put
on each one of the latent factors and
similar to PCA we get a strongest weight
in the upper left hand corner in this
case which corresponds with the general
cell line growth rate all right so how
am I going assess whether this method
works well impair the performance to
those some of those methods that I
mentioned earlier the best performing
from the dream seven and Matt Matt's
other method of incorporating drug and
cell line information at the same time I
want to see if incorporating dose really
on its own improve performance much and
there's different types of prediction
tasks that we can do so we can leave out
a particular cell line drug combination
all doses for that and then try to
predict it so to do those types of
predictions i'll do a fivefold
cross-validation so leaving out twenty
percent of those combinations and
predicting on those and then comparing
to the actual observed outcomes or we
can actually just predict for a whole
cell line at every drug how it would
respond to every good and this is really
what we want for a type of personalized
or precision medicine we want to know
for a new patient how are they going to
respond for all these different drugs so
for that I'll leave out one cell line
and make predictions across all drugs or
one drug and make predictions across all
cell lines and compare alright so moving
on towards my second aim where I'm going
to try to combine multiple studies in a
slightly larger tensor to make sense of
this type of data from multiple studies
at the same time so these two papers
which came out in the last two years
John Quackenbush is group are really
kind of calling attention to the fact
that there's been several of these large
cell line drug panel screening efforts
and they haven't necessarily reproduced
the same results so this is one figure
from their second paper just kind of
showing the differences between the
studies and why so this is comparing two
studies the CC le or cancer cell line
encyclopedia and the c GP or Cancer
Genome Project and they have kind of
moderate concordance and how they see
their gene expression but low
concordance in what they see as
responses to different drugs like which
cell lines will respond to which drugs
and low concordance in between the
relationship suit that they find between
the genetics and this and the drug
response and some of the reasons are
these red boxes what's different between
the two studies there's a lot of
differences in the way that the studies
performed how they grow the cells and
plate them and I think well one of the
things that my method will address fully
is this differences in how they model
the dose response curve all right they
use different methods for fitting the
curb and different measures of response
between the two studies so this is my
second name to combine in this case for
studies in now a four dimensional tensor
that's going to capture all the
information of these studies and use
them to try to try to understand why
there's differences between these
studies for the same type of prediction
outcome this is an overview of the data
for the four studies so the first one
will be the data from aim one these next
two big studies are the ones that I
mentioned in the previous paper they
have hundreds of cell lines hundreds of
drugs so it's a large amount of data to
deal with but the sensor methods should
be able to handle this fairly naturally
and the CTD too I forget what the
acronym stands for cancer target
discovery and development is another
large study with a lot of some overlap
between with cell lines of drugs of the
previous one so here's some of the
overlap I didn't include
data from the first study which I don't
know if I was clear about the data on
the first study is just breast cancer
cell lines these studies across multiple
cancer types so the overlap there's some
overlap between for instance of si si le
and the c GP or Sanger data in the
method the sensor model should be able
to leverage this overlap for predictions
and to understand what what elements of
the experimental differences are really
accounting for the difference is found
between these study here's what the
model looks like 482 it's very similar
to the previous model for aim one the
differences are I've added in an extra
dimension here that incorporates that
summarizes the differences in the
experimental conditions between the
studies so there'll be a row here for
each of the four studies and columns
kind of indicating what growth media
they use indifferent experimental
differences between the studies so that
those experimental differences can now
be linked to the drug response data as
well also the central tensor is now this
four-dimensional hypercube and the last
aim is that clock right oh yeah okay I'm
going a little bit fast bigger the last
name here is to try to get towards some
of the actual biological evidence
supporting what we find in these studies
so I'm going to look at this RNAi
screening data from something called the
Achilles project and i'll look at
published cell line pathways in the
database to try to look at connections
between the genomics and the drug
features so about this project Achilles
this is a totally separate type of data
which should be able to which we can use
it since it's a completely separate
platform for some type of validation so
what they do here is they in fact sells
a good amount of the overlapping cell
lines from what we saw in the previous
aim in tech cells with short hairpin
rnas which are processed processed sin
this
all interfering RNAs each of which
targets one specific gene so the kind of
orange plasmid here would target one
gene and stop its function the green one
would target a different genes topics
function and so on and then they grow
the cells so and then they count
basically how many cells are left after
growing for a certain amount of time so
if the orange gene is important when we
knock it down we're going to have less
cells grown over time that's why it's
called project Achilles we're really
trying to determine which genes are
important for that cell to grow so we're
kind of looking at something similar in
our study where we can see we can look
at literature to see what genes of
particular drug targets and then we can
see whether mutations in that gene or
expression of that gene in the cell line
is correlated with the weather that cell
line response to that drug so for a
given drug here that gets projected
through to these latent factors that
incorporate some of the information on
the structural features of the drug
which is somewhere this quartet sir that
latent factor we can examine which
latent factors about the cell lines are
most highly weighted against the
information from that drug and trace it
back through the projection matrix and
these ideas of kind of eigen genes of
groups of genes that are regulated
together or have the same effect on
specific structural features and compare
that in using permutation analysis to
see whether these are represented these
these whatever genes are pulled out by
this projection metric matrix are more
often represented than would be expected
by chance in targeting that particular
drug so the database I'm going to use
for this is the CPD p which is a
compendium of a bunch of different
databases so that's the consensus
pathway database as pulls together 32
different databases with over 4,000
pathways which I'll be able to examine
to really look for evidence of whether
the relationships I find my model have
been found in literature previously and
whether
relationships found in literature
previously are over-represented in my
model in terms of these permutation
analysis this is the timeline so I hope
to get this all done in around two years
I want to publish at least two maybe
three papers off of it the first aim and
this first tensor method is more of a
technical paper and then the second one
really trying to make sense of those
disparate data sets pulling them
together I think will be a bigger more
bioinformatics paper like the kind of
boring and just overall impact what does
this new method going to do ok so for
aim one we've got this whole new method
will be able to predict responses for
new cell lines and new drugs and also
tease apart some of these relationships
between so I drove aim to we're going to
combine these data sets that until now
it's been kind of worrisome that they
haven't been finding the same things so
now we're in a unified framework that we
can make sense of them all my name three
we're really going to look towards
mechanism is this is what we find what
this method supported by literature and
rnai information and all the code that I
write is going to be written in art and
shared freely with the community and if
you just take a second and think about
it as my last slide I just want to think
about some extensions and how broad this
kind of framework is and how it could be
used for a bunch of other things so kind
of on the first level we could have all
kinds of different input data on the
cell lines or the drugs we could include
a lot of lot more descriptive things
without the epigenetics of the cell line
it could even have properties of imaging
data from what the cells look like grown
indifferent yet so on we could
incorporate that RNAi screening data as
well as input into the cell lines for
our predictions and any of these might
might improve the prediction a lot also
we can think about what other dimensions
could we have on this tensor okay maybe
the cell line is not responding to the
drug just because of its genetics or
because of the experimental conditions
that I
there maybe there's something about the
micro environment in which it's grown
and we can add an extra dimension
detailing the surrounding of the cells
that that's grown in a different type of
culture or a different extracellular
matrix or different signaling factors
around it and there's a big project
going on starting here at ohsu through
the links grant for this type of data of
micro environment microarray will be
growing where there will be growing
cells in different micro environments
and seeing how those micro environments
influence the growth of the cells so
that was one extension that I had in
mind from the beginning of the study and
hope to work on that data as well once I
have this framework set up and I know
there's some clinicians out there you
can really see this being used directly
for patients if we had instead of
outcomes these measures from cell lines
we have some direct measure of clinical
outcome we can have as input dimensions
of obviously genomics but also possibly
the environment of the person maybe even
something about their micro and buyer in
micro biome or the treatment schedule or
dosage of the drugs so the huge number
of different factors that we could try
to incorporate into one of these sensors
in order to make predictions on a broad
number of different categories different
types of problems here so that is all i
have i'd like to thank my committee the
my department d mice NLM fellows but let
me practice my talk will go to the lab
for also letting me practice my talk Joe
and Laura for giving me a meeting with
me and I've given the advice on the
project in general NLM for funding and
of course my friends and family out
there and ask for any questions
putting go too fast just a reminder if
you ask questions because it's being
recorded especially for people watching
it live just press the button and hold
it down while you're talking well
totally clear yes wow great great talk
thank you our clinical decisions being
made today on some of these studies that
have not been replicated uh I don't know
that I don't think so not yet these some
of these studies have replicated things
that have been found so basically
they're normally users screening studies
where you'd want to if you find a
relationship between some genetic
feature and some drug response you'd
want to examine that further with a
clinical trial beep well a few steps
before you get to the clinical trial so
these cell lines are are fairly early in
the pipeline in terms of drug
development but it does have an economic
costs because and and bear and others
have done internal studies in which
they've seen that over a quarter or more
of the portfolio can't be reproduced and
those are all things that continued on
in the pipeline so that has a really
immediate aspect in terms of either
choices and other things that could have
come in for the cost or both um so very
nice talk I have a question for you guys
thinking about it and I should have
brought it up earlier but we have a lot
of information more and more now about
the actual specificity of or premium
security of the drugs and I'm wondering
if you're actually explicitly
incorporating that I know I brought up
before the idea of the relationship with
a correlation among the drugs because
many of them can be related but I was
just wondering if you're explicitly
looking at that because that could be
interesting especially we're thinking
about error right where you have drugs
that are either highly specific or you
have drugs that potentially have a lot
of off targeting or other aspects where
you would kind of see you can cross
signal or noise and some of the other
cell lines where you might not expect a
response and you're seeing your response
right so so you're saying this will
increase generally the noise and the
response to that
given drug or maybe that drug will be
have higher specificity in a certain
genetic background than others I think
that those type of relationships I mean
so with the sensor method we should be
able to well we will be able to have
some measure of the variance across the
measurements right so depending on how I
train it yeah the and I have a couple
different methods that I've been
thinking up yeah we'll have some measure
of not just what we expect for the
outcome at each dose but what's the
variance that we expect for the outcome
and eight shows so we can connect that
variance to drug properties as well and
for specific drugs we can look through
that push that particular column through
the tensor and try to see whether the
variance correlates with certain
features of the drugs or search for
specific drugs whether there's higher
variance and now but I think I mean I
don't want to speak for Shannon but it's
either I think she was asking what it is
can be used as a like a side information
because you know that and can you use
that to strain or constrain your model
for better prediction or this is my
follow up a tree so this is why I
understood seriously so as an input to
the drug kind of matrix some information
about the specificity of the drug as a
predictor yeah I think that's a really
good idea but I'll have to think about
where I would find that we can talk
offline but I think it actually could be
really informative especially because
some of the some of that data is good
and some of its actually prediction
itself and so it could be really
interesting to incorporate it and then
be able to also assess those are some of
the ones that are more computational
rather than expres Mel this work have
you ever thought about adapting it to
incorporate sort of a continuous update
of time of your variables so for example
usually when we think about patients in
an HR database there some of their
variables are continually changing and
being updated and we wait at one day
capture a continuous stream of biometric
data and then
say apply your method and it might be
adaptable to that kind of data in the
future yeah I think that's a something
that I probably should have put on the
extensions right that's a really good
point so a lot of the tensor methods
well a lot of uses for tensor methods
have incorporated some element of time
so one study was predicting what uses
tensor factorization to predict movie
ratings but they also incorporated a
time element so maybe you know this
movie is more popular at this time and
then later not so much so yeah
definitely I think moving towards the
clinic that makes a lot of sense and
especially with this kind of multi task
prediction we can predict at each time
point or use the previous time points to
predict the next one similar as we might
use previous doses predict the next goes
up with you it'll be your stock yeah I
mean there's so many extensions for this
I'm really excited about the idea so
first of all great talk and I think you
set the bar really really really really
really high out so I have two questions
one is if you go back a few slides where
you're talking about your tensor and
dimensions of the various things let's
go the matrices that are going in it
keep going like maybe like five slides
back yeah sorry about that that's good
enough one more for it is going to so
how do you make sure that the dimensions
of the matrix that are going into your
tensor are appropriate for that tensor
factorization right so that's kind of
what I was getting at here right so I
tried some different sizes
decompositions so this was reducing the
data basically by a factor of four and I
was able to get good reproduction of the
outcome values so that's basically what
i'm going to use as the indication like
can without being linked to this to the
genomics and the drug features just
can't i reproduce the data that's in the
tensor ok then i'm really holding enough
of the information in these factor
matrices that that's a decent size so i
plan on when i write the script trying
it with different sizes on xicot in
parallel so and finding which ones seem
to have the lowest error when I
reproduce the essential tensor yeah
we're gonna wear an optimized exactly so
yeah we'll have four different values of
this decomposition different dimensions
well yeah look at the error function I
mean another way to do it is more
complicated is to try to do it with
Bayesian methods where you have an
objective function that actually takes
into account that error and something
about those dimensions as well and it
allows it to change the dimensions while
you're training which is another
possibility of seeing some papers that
do things similar to that but uh so that
might be a further down the road
development of the method for now I
think I'm just going to try a bunch and
see which one that is able to reproduce
the central tensor so I'm sure that I'm
capturing the full amount of information
um thank you and I guess my second
question is how do you deal with cell
line generation and I mean what I mean
by that is as cell lines move through
time and which like Saturday generation
they're taking you know sampling from
they might differ and so cell line BTW
474 might have a different drug response
when it was first thought out in first
20 days which is a 40-day in culture how
do you do with that so that is a problem
and that I think will so if there's for
the saw ones that are existing in two
different studies I think that's where
it'll be the most problem in my second
day more I'm combining different studies
and they have different versions of the
same cell lines that might have been
growing separately for possibly decades
at sometimes like people have seen and
ready to the genome on hela right
there's a lot of differences and some of
these ela cell lines that have been
growing forever so that's some some
possible difference between these so one
way to incorporate it in the the second
model is I'm going to have
characterizations of the genetics from
each of these different studies that can
go into the cell line matrix as a
prediction okay so i won't just have
like a block of expression data for cell
line a i'll have block of expression
data for selling a from study one and
block of expression data from Silla a
from study to
okay so in with the sparsity prior on
the projection matrix I will hopefully
be choosing well it will choose one or
the other of those expression data to
use as its prediction passing through
the rest of the model so the
characterization if I that's a good idea
i should look out for it for differences
in whether it's going to choose one or
the other the see the expression data
from the different studies and we can
compare those expression data like when
the figure i put up from the paper
comparing study showed moderate
concordance and the genomics between the
different studies so yeah it's something
to keep an eye on again and there's also
been some recent papers about selling
contamination some of these studies have
done a good job of making sure they're
not contaminated and gone through a lot
of steps to see that each cell light is
different one of them less so you could
though directly incorporated as metadata
into aim to if you have that information
the problem is in all study if you want
but if you actually know passage or if
you know purity or if you have any of
that that could easily be at it as well
yeah so right in the experimental
differences matrix yeah any other
questions I just join me in thanking him
one more time thank you so the videos to
meet you reference for learning about
doing process maps and for using tools
that assist in building process maps
because I talk football he recommended
car me and I think that that's what I'll
have to do at harmony really carmate
mcmullen Roger process maps apparently
she does process my party recommend
everybody um I think that I will have to
build process maps and what I was
planning to do was to get video of you
know clinical teams doing simulated
little codes and I want to build the
process maps and analyze this data
orthogonal II like same team different
sims in different sim sing safety so i
can analyze changes to the structure and
then changes to the to the state and
dynamics of the system